[Music]
thank you
um so my secret
is that I am way more depressed than
people think it's really hard for me to
do small tasks which sounds ridiculous
but
um yeah I have a hard time just doing
normal daily things but now I'm crying
great
um but yeah that's been on my mind a lot
recently just because it's gotten so
much worse and my life is starting to
pick up and life stops for no one so
just trying to keep up
I'll walk straight
[Music]
my friends and family view me as the
strongest person they know but every day
I wake up I have a crippling fear and
anxiety of everything in the world
all right my secret is
um I am always afraid
and I've always been that way since I
was a kid
um I'm ready to get emotional about it
um
Everything I Do I Do is scared
but
um as I've gotten older I've tried to
put myself out there like picking up
martial arts or picking up music trying
to be able to hopefully in the future
perform for people so that I get rid of
my fear of being seen
and I think that mostly like stems from
not being confident since I was young
um and I think that's why I always try
to overcompensate and try to pick up
something new learn something new and
yeah I don't know I guess that's it
do I turn
[Music]
I'm pretty sure no matter what I do I
don't think my in-laws are gonna ever
accept me and love me as well as my
other sister-in-law
and I don't know if it's because I'm A
different race or I grew up in a
different religious belief
but it's been eight years
and I don't think things are going to
change
and that breaks me
I love my girlfriend and we've been
together for a long time but I sometimes
feel that I may not be living up to the
things that she wants from me
and I only hope that I can
be everything that she wants me to be
[Music]
My secret is that when my brother
younger brother would fall asleep
without completing his homework I would
do it for him so that he wouldn't get in
trouble with his teachers
My secret is when I was in the second
grade and we would get homework packets
and I wouldn't understand how to do some
of the homework I would cut those pieces
of paper out of the packet just so that
I would act like they never existed you
could literally see the cut marks on the
paper and nobody ever found out and I'm
here to this day
[Music]
when I was young I always tried singing
and dancing in front of people and
people always did not like it but I
don't really care as long as I enjoy it
um and yeah whenever I'm by myself I
still sin I still dance I think I'm
pretty good at it
[Music]
My secret is I Z I've never been in love
and I still have this hope that my
life's gonna be like a romantic comedy
movie and if I can't have it like that
I rather not have anything at all
honestly
I turn on incognito mode on Spotify when
I listen to Taylor Swift and Harry
Styles because I'm embarrassed that some
of my music taste is really mainstream
[Music]
all right so every time I travel places
I like to blend in with the crowd so I
wear their hats and their gear just so I
don't feel you know kind of an outsider
for some reason I've always had trouble
fitting in so I like to you know blend
in with my surroundings a little bit
just so I don't seem too out of place
when I blend in I feel like I'm one of
everyone else and when I kind of stand
out I feel a little you know out in the
open a little bit
um
especially like I said I'm from 3 000
miles away so this is like a new area
I'm also a big sports fan so blending in
with the gear and stuff kind of makes me
feel you know at home away from home
okay
um hi so my secret is that I always feel
like
there's no one in this world who can
accept me for who I am just because of
my identity just with the way I look I'm
almost 30 but like I always felt like
it's
never been easy just to find someone to
be with that can accept me from who I am
and yeah that's my secret
[Music]
all right so growing up I've always had
this
fear of like in public like in
public restrooms and I think it started
when I was young I was like in first
grade and we'd all as a class we'd go to
the restroom together and I just
couldn't hold it in and so
I myself and it went down my leg
you know out my pants and so like you
know I just kind of shook it off on the
ground and I just you know as a kid I
was like I didn't want to draw attention
to myself so I was like ew someone just
on the ground I I guess I didn't
change my underwear to like after school
I told my mom and um yeah that was that
was it
uh sorry for the haircut I I'm getting
one tomorrow so you don't have to look
at this mess for too long
um I've been always a very happy guy at
to the outside world and I've always
wanted to be a good role model to my
neighbors and to my peers and to the
people that I work with
and uh
a lot of people just don't know that
I feel lost and broken
and it's scary
because I don't know what I do I don't
know what I want to do with my life and
I just I feel lost and I wish I could
find
something to help me out to help me get
on the right path
and uh I'm still searching so
[Music]
my deepest fear is to be at the end of
the world and having nobody to hold my
hand
why is that that's always been on my
mind because I study environmental
science so I'm very worried about
climate change and it's also on my mind
because my family has never been my
support system
and friends have always been my family
my chosen family but my friends have
their own families who they would go to
at the end of the world so you know it
was all I always felt like I didn't have
anybody
but then this got all way realer because
I almost died from cancer and I felt
like I fought for my life literally when
I was in the hospital and uh but my
friends were there for me and my friends
saved my life so it was a really real
manifestation
and tests of my greatest fear but I got
through it and I'm still here so yeah
um no I'm not yet completely recovered I
got really good news uh earlier last
week
um the cancer was completely removed
from the tumor it was completely taken
out it was in my tongue that's why I
sound like this it's very weird I'm only
21 years old
um but I'm going to be doing radiation
therapy starting here in about
four weeks or so yeah and then I'll be
better for cancer but it's a part of my
journey now I don't know if I'm allowed
to curse but yeah I actually very
specific advice
um
my friend knows where I'm going with
this
um
ladies get pap smears
um young people watch out for HPV I have
my vaccines
and HPV still gave me cancer somehow
less than three percent chance so to
everybody especially young people take
care of yourself and your soul and take
care of your body because you never know
when something like this could happen I
am a completely healthy person besides
my cancer it's bizarre I read a really
powerful book before I started this all
and it totally Rings true that
the best drug
or alcohol you could ever take is to
have a healthy body and to be able to do
what you want to do on your terms with
that body
whenever you want and to love the people
and hug the people that you love with
that body
so yeah there's no there's no better
drug than that but it's true I mean it
is true and yeah that's all
I'm so wise now
[Laughter]
any more questions
[Music]
Ah that's dramatic
um I'll probably I'll probably walk
because
uh yeah
can I dance straight
oh yeah
[Music]
hi everyone thank you for watching I'll
be posting bonus footage from this
episode on my patreon that means more
answers and extended cuts of each answer
if you want to see it you can sign up
I'll have it linked in my description
and if I ever do follow-ups on the
people you see in this episode that'll
be on my patreon as well thank you guys
for watching I love you all and I'll see
you next time